it's almost unheard of to see this
number of Afghan special forces in one
place at one time
they're regrouping in Kabul they're well
trained and heavily armed together
they're a formidable Force
but they're desperately needed in the
capital that Taliban are just miles away
now
steadily the British and American
soldiers and crucially their equipment
are arriving at Kabul
transporter planes land and crisscross
the runways moving towards the military
section of the airport complex
vitally important helicopter gunships
have been prepared for imminent
deployment to protect the evacuation of
foreign Nationals and the Afghan workers
employed here for two decades
the 600 British soldiers from the 16th
Air Assault Brigade have been loaded
onto planes and will immediately secure
the airport and prepare to assist in the
withdrawal on arrival
it's hoped these British and American
troops will cause the Taliban to
hesitate in attacking
Afghanistan's president ashrafghani is
quickly losing his grip here
many thought he would stand down but
he's told a nation he intends to restore
order
our dear country Afghanistan is in
serious danger of instability due to the
war imposed on us I'm aware of the
situation in Afghanistan in the current
situation the reintegration of the
security and Defense Forces is our
priority in serious measures are being
taken in this regard
in the midst of tightening security the
government held hours of talks
discussing a Taliban Alpha of a
ceasefire and an interim government it
came to nothing
for both the government and the Taliban
have rejected previous proposals that
could have brought about a ceasefire in
some form of power sharing the latest
proposal from the Taliban involved the
president standing down which he's
rejected the fact that he said he's
going to go after the Taliban can only
mean bad news for Kabul and more
importantly for the people who live here
many we spoke to said all they wanted
was peace and some said they'd accept
the Taliban especially if they showed
they had changed right now it's fine the
the people is good with them they they
said everyone can go to school the girls
the boys life is normal but in the
future we don't know right yes but right
recently life has become difficult for
people people worried about how
the way Taliban tree does before and now
it's a little different the question is
can you trust them to be nice well we
just want peace
but the early indicators of a reformed
Taliban aren't looking good in Kandahar
they've taken over the radio station
it's now Sharia radio
women know they'll suffer the most only
a few are so defined
[Music]
are you scared now I'm not desperate if
I'm a girl you know I know that Taliban
is fighting and
um
that's the entry gate of Kabul they are
here I'm not afraid of them we are not
the people who will you know go back to
the dark era I'm a girl and I don't care
about anyone North Pakistan not America
nobody else I'm here even today if they
kill me if they identify me I will not
care about them
I will not care about him well what
should I be scared of this is my
homeland my land
change is coming here now whatever the
President says the taliban's inexorable
Advance on Kabul is almost complete
the Coalition forces were likely only
delay the inevitable
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Kabul